that's Bob is a lot like strict on
tearing like the rotations on domination
yeah i agree with aah yeah that's what
that's about I think good work for
amnesia or you this is done this is dorm
yet esto y it's actually really like
this exact same no it's not there's an
extra bit tap water inside we're all
right oh yeah that's that's the bus the
wooden make order there's another car of
it you go through that oh you can toss
annoying was why I cigs I'll the same as
well forget it what we've seen so far
all formats are baked full scores very
much just a small map fair DLC but you
let you said for like great fair enough
mrs. you're on top adore Martha silence
mayor's GG I'm gonna try this on track
I'm gonna try silence with all their arm
going up in the cranberries zombie
zombie you can see be from in the crane
I'll just make sure
like a crane in the middle and they're
open it and you can see I definitely
like all of the flag bottom see this
could definitely work but this is what
matters yeah definitely i can Kyle good
show you see what I've got I've one
alien following me around seekers look
um yeah I just got some aliens yeah I
got Philly Oh Mayday artair enough I
want them they patch it then you would
get thing girls are full specialist
right what what's actually didn't have
to shoot hey I'm not doing anything
right I'll get perfect hey they got in
the crane nah that's that's not fair
when it comes to council offices down
but one of the enemy team that's unfair
I spent 10 minutes shooting that crane
and I saw what about if I get in the
crane & % you got in there I mean it I
mean it what do i do actually bring out
they can use my pen tool in it you scum
I hear is everybody from so is everyone
for himself right salutes come yeah I'm
in the crane with an LM silence OMG
there's no way they can even see me I'm
going to harm with this thing well I'm
do we got them but Griffin I was like
your Griffin is yes it is don't shoot it
please Oh bullseye did you just get me
with it I knew Oh after your flow that
plays a lot of called G like peppers are
there though of the box maps are gonna
eventually get about tedious you're
gonna want to invest it's not a great
amount of cash and to have that sort of
extra enjoyment and again so instead I
say it's worth a hundred percent